je file avec sa mère eric sa mère j'ai
quitté la ville pour pour retourner à
mes amours d'enfance c'est à dire la
nature la compagne du bate voltaire et
chevauchent c'est à dire que ce sont des
chiens qui vivent avec les choses qui
sont décontractés
et qui n'ont qui n'ont pas peur et qui
sont capables de de galoper de courir
derrière les chevaux pendant 20 km est
absolument fatigué
puis c'est le mali s'appelle vote
il fait 80 kg il est très pacifique
c'est un gros chien de garde sûrement
mais on peut rien lui apprendre sinon à
ce mec comme ça voilà et après peut-être
s'il est disposé à venir sur mes épaules
bien mais là on voit toute sa taille
vous voyez c'est une grosse bête sur les
grosses bêtes mais des caractères
merveilleux une grande grande force
les chiens très très isolée c'est la
femelle
c'est vrai le mag limogé kg 1 kg de
viande par jour de viande crue avec un
oeuf
c'est beaucoup mais on a des combinés
avec les abattoirs
il faut aussi un chien s'en occuper il
faut il a vraiment besoin au moins
pendant une demi heure 30 minutes par
jour celle ci par exemple elle a besoin
que je m'occupe d'elle que je
m'intéresse à j'ai eu comme une actrice
comme ça qui a élevé un saint bernard
dans sa salle de bain et qui était très
surprise parce qu ils aillent avait les
reins complètement creux non je suis
évidemment sur ses ongles sur le
carrelage salle de bain le chien a
grandi comme ça elle sait poser quelques
questions ça aussi je veux dire c'est la
même chose à voir des chiens ça demande
un effort ça demande du travail et pas
seulement de les aimer deux façons
complètement absurde je veux dire il
faut suffit pas de les aimer aussi se
fatiguer pour essayer de les comprendre
et essayer de les aider
c'est le même problème que pour les
choses
oh
où
alors ça ça c'est ma jument c'était fini
ça ça oui parce qu'on dit toujours qu un
cavalier toujours
j'ai eu un cheval dans ma vie alors je
crois que
grâce à c'est une séquence d'un et
france attend énormément ses films
d'yves robert que je fais avec brasseur
victor lanoux guy bedos danièle delorme
et anny duperey les séquences qu'on peut
voir là était passionnante pour moi
parce que bon il fallait que je fasse
semblant toute modestie gardée pas
monter monter du tout à cheval alors que
ça fait 20 ans que j'essaie de pénétrer
les secrets de l'équitation française et
heureusement j'ai une jument qui se
prête fort bien ce genre d'exercice
voyez là elle saute une table avec des
gens qui sont c'est toute ma famille
d'ailleurs qui s'est prêté à cette
figuration dangereuses elles nagent dans
un étang c'est à dire elle est très très
calme elle a très équilibré c'est du
monde remonte qu'à dans un étang avec
elle au moment où elle perd pied à elle
continue tout droit en agent et je sais
pas si c'est pas fréquent les chevaux
qui nagent avec un cavalier sur le dos
ils me disent pas dit qu'ils disent et
frais
je lui côtes et l'avaient quatre ans
maintenant elle en attrait c'est pas
vieux pour un cheval de concours
hippique un cheval de promenade est en
pleine forme j'ai fait des années de
compétition à laquelle maintenant c'est
ma fille qui fait les championnats
juniors ça va très très bien
on n'a rien à lui reprocher elle a
toujours été gentille elle a toujours
était douce toujours en bonne santé
e
je dois être un petit peu et il alla
s'est construit du reportage
pourquoi on vit avec les chevaux
pourquoi je vis à gauche trop pourquoi
ma femme et moi devions un cash flow
ça fait 15 ans je peux pas le définir
exactement c'est un contact sont des
émotions des joies d enthousiasme mais
aussi des peines vous avez vu tout à
l'heure et c'est pas la peine de le
cacher un à poulain parce que la danse
près il ya deux poulains de 18 mois en
tant qu est le fils de ma jument préféré
que j'ai depuis dix ans et ce poulain
est né ici je partais en tunisie on a vu
avec chabrol et puis ma jument était
plein on attendait d'un jour à l'autre
qu'elle mette bas alors juste avant de
partir j'avais mes valises et je suis
allé la voir j'ai mon beau costume pour
prendre l'avion et je fais des coutumes
décide pas ça serait bien de faire
maintenant ton poulain mais je le vois
que je le connais je portais pour
plusieurs semaines
elle n'a pas voulu tout de suite je suis
parti en tunisie et ma femme m'a
téléphoné et il était minuit et dit ça y
est c'est un poulain comment ça s'est
passé
ben tout à coup marie ma fille a crié ma
femme se précipiter sur le téléphone
pour appeler le vétérinaire le télé le
vétérinaire le téléphone pour ça
répondait pas tout de suite et ma fille
qui avait 12 ans et demi est arrivée
dans la maison avec du sang un peu
partout en ce moment c'est pas la peine
d'appeler le vétérinaire
ça y est il est né j'ai vu les sabots
sortir j'ai tiré et puis voilà
il est là bon très bien ça c'est la joie
c'est le plaisir c'est le bonheur et
puis vous avez filmé à l'instant ce même
poulain qui canopée avec un autre son
compagnon de jeu et puis il est tombé il
est tombé pourquoi parce qu'il est mal à
dallas myélite on a appris ça ya deux
semaines ce poulain probablement
condamné on l'a élevé pendant 18 mois on
l'a vu grandir grossi à devenir fort
être gay s'amuser
puis depuis deux trois semaines on sait
que c'est fini on garde un petit espoir
si vous toujours garder un petit espoir
puis je veux pas que ça soit trop triste
cette émission simplement pour qu'on
sache que la vie avec les animaux c'est
la vie avec la vie mais c'est aussi la
vie avec la mort et ça c'est souvent
très très dur et c'est ce que nous
ressentons ma femme et moi aujourd'hui
choix
il faut lui donner son travail lui
fournir un travail et nous nous relayons
toute la famille pour tous les jours
brandt et au minimum une heure chaque
cheval qui fasse son travail pour qu'il
s'entraine qui sous un buisson
c'est comme ça que l'harmonie existe
entre nous
je suis venu aussi avec un grand vin
qu'un grand cheval plus foncé était très
maigre on est très tristes de présenter
un cheval très mer mais ça c'est
l'anecdote connaissance ce cheval il a
couru il a fait gagner le tiercé aux
français et puis il a gagné beaucoup de
courses il a été fort il a six ans il
n'est pas vieux du tout et puis les
jambons fatigués on lui a demandé
tellement d'efforts on lui a tellement
demandé de gagner que les tendons était
plus faible que le coeur puisqu'il a un
courage énorme mais les jambes
elles ont refusé dans l'effort alors on
essaie de soigner le sauver ça va durer
huit mois un an ni arrivera ça on va
mettre toutes nos forces pour y arriver
enfin pas qu'ils soient trop gros parce
que si on le nourrit trop s'il est gay
s'il retrouve vraiment le bonheur de
vivar courir comme un fou comme à
longchamp comme à auteuil 20 partout et
puis va encore se répéter un tendon
avant que ce fameux tendant de soins
guéri c'est pour ça que l'habitude
échoue à la connaissance des shows fait
que nous nous nourrissons peu pour
qu'ils ne soient pas trop peureux trop
gay que les jambes redevienne forte et
le jour les jambes seront fortes
alors il mangera vraiment plein plein
plein il sera gros gros gros il serait
très heureux il vivra j'espère avec
toute sa force et sa gaieté de vrai
cheval
voilà
marié et juliette et vous comment ça se
passait très bien on a un professeur
une fois j'ai appris sur vous vous tenez
bien vous êtes spolie parce qu'on est
filmé s'est bien passé oui j'ai déjà et
je leur ai donné à manger parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas tous à manger c'est toi tu
leur donnera manger ce soir à 19 heures
parce que moi je sors on sera pas là
avec alexandre imbeault j'ai donné du
pain qu'on sait bien je prenais une
telle haine mais c'est comme ça tous les
soirs quand on attire ans parce que bon
aujourd'hui c'est jour de classe mais
bon quand on a des animaux à la maison
là aussi il faut s'en occuper alors tout
le monde a sa petite responsabilité on
voit ainsi julien il fait il passe en
revue les chevaux voir si tout va bien
marie ce soir quand elle aura fini ses
devoirs ira donner à manger à 7h30 niais
et toujours quelque chose à faire a bien
fait d'aller voir les choux et de
surveiller tout parce que ya aussi la
compétence qui est nécessaire c'est à
voir des animaux aimer les animaux c'est
bien mais faut aussi s'en occuper et d
c'est bien que je vois que tu rentres
d'école six mois si on n'est pas là sur
un jeune homme qui va et puis tu
regardes si si tout va bien si tout est
en ordre
c'est bien je suis content qu'ils
m'aiment pas beaucoup reçu
j'adore vraiment mais c'est parce que
j'ai du succès au léman beaucoup plus
mais non quel mauvais esprits scandale
il s'attache à toi petit à petit si toi
tu ne tache pas lui pirates